there are people out there who want to
change the way that you count they want
to change the world so that we stop
counting
using ten symbols and start counting
using twelve symbols
I love them I think these guys are great
let's talk about what we know so far so
the way we count is the decimal system
it uses ten symbols so let's let's just
write those out first of all zero 1 2 8
9 once we get to this point we start to
have to make our numbers using
combinations of the symbols we've
already got 12 13 14 32 33 now if we had
been born with six fingers on each hand
then we would have twelve fingers and
maybe we would have started using
something called the dozenal system
where it's based on twelve symbols and
there are some people out there who
think this is the system we should be
using with they think we should have six
fingers on each hand the
disappointed we don't have six fingers
on each hand because they think it's a
much easier way to count so first of all
if we're going to use 12 symbols any two
extra let's have a look what they
suggest for 10 we're going to have a
symbol like this that's called deck and
for 11 we're going to have a symbol like
this which is called L so now it reads 0
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 deck I'll this would
be 12 in fact where they say doh so this
is doh doh 1 doh - doh 3 Doh for dou v
dou 6.7 donate don't I dodecahedron it's
the exact same idea there's no
difference between the
system and the decimal system that would
be three dough
this would be four dough and you keep
going you get nine dough then you'd get
Dec dough l dough and then you're going
to get dodo dodo twelve twelve twelve
twelve that's 144 12 tails or gross so
if we write that out twelve trails will
be written like this
it's 144 or gross or grow so that would
be a grow something like this would be a
mo so if we take this year bikes 2012
which is a good year to pick since we're
talking about twelve so if we took the
year 2012 in the dozenal system is
written like this that is mow grow l 8
that's the current year if you count in
base twelve now there is a reason why
these guys want to count this way
because they say is going to make a
rithmetic much easier I want to make
this clear for seamless maths this
system would not make any difference but
for day-to-day life for your regular
shopping these guys reckon that this 12
system would make life a much easier
because of the number of factors that 12
has so 10 has let's see how many factors
that have it has 110 has 2 5 and 10
itself but 12 has much more factors it
has 1 it has to it has 3 it has 4 has 6
and it has 12 itself the reason this is
useful is it will make calculations
using thirds and quarters much easier
than they are in decimal let's do
something that I get a 4 times table if
we did that in decimal it would look
like this
ok it's 4 and then 2 times 4 is 8 3
times 4 is 12 4 times 4 is 16 5 times 4
is 20 if we did it with the dozenal
system then it would have 4
and we would have eight then we would
have dough which is their word for 12
then we have dough for dough eight - Doh
- dough for - dough eight three dough
and so on this pattern is a much easier
pattern to teach children four eight
zero four eight zero four eight zero
then the patterns are much easier to see
but the real strength of it is when you
start dividing if we wanted something
like one-third you know in decimal that
this is not point three three three
three R it goes on forever which is
fairly ugly but in the docile dog system
it suddenly becomes really nice if I
want to write 1/3 so that'd be four out
of dough 4 out of 12 is 1/3 four out of
dough which is equal to not point for
1/3 written in this system is not point
four it's not something that goes on
forever
that's does a thing that decimal does
it's horrible in dozenal it doesn't
happen let's do something else
let's do a quarter a quarter of twelve
quarter of dough is three out of dough
which would be not point three a half
would be six out of dough which is not
point six if you want to do a six that
would be two out of dough which is not
point to suddenly all these become much
simply you can see now why they start
though I they like it suddenly all those
horrible things that happen in decimal
don't happen in Gosnell if we had been
born with six fingers on each hand and
this is the system we have learned and
and I came to you and said no I've got
an idea let's not use base twelve let's
use base 10 you would laugh in my face
why would you use base 10 it's not as
good now naturally we actually count in
twelve in historically weights and
measures were in twelve so you would
have feet and inches 12 inches to a foot
and currency was counted in
as well because it was naturally made
dividing by 1/2 divided by thirds and
divided my quarters and sixths much more
easy and much more practical and that's
what that's the system we had then in
the French Revolution the the French got
obsessed with decimal izing everything
they wanted to make weights and measures
easier to use so they wanted to decimal
ice it divided into a hundred because
because that we use the decimal system
now they had a choice they could have
decimalised everything or they could
have changed the way we counted from ten
to twelve if they had done that they
could have kept all the weights and
measures the same and all the
calculations would have been as easy to
do in dozenal as they are today in
decimal
now they chose to make things metric and
keep the system maybe they made the
wrong choice in facts in the French
Revolution they went so mad with
decimalisation that they had a decimal
week they had a decimal calendar and a
decimal clock as well they did that for
a few years didn't take off
what would part of a one prior be the
same so if we talk about serious maths
something like pi it would look a lot
different and it would involve these dec
symbols and elf symbols and if we look
at it it looks weird and unusual but if
you are born with this system it would
be fine it would be normal
there's no significant difference in the
mathematics the real difference this
would make would be to touch your
regular life and might make it might
make arithmetic easier for children as
well but one thing I guess people are
going to say is when you are very small
and learning about numbers your fingers
and your hands are a really useful
learning aid you'd be taking that away
from children right at the start there
well to answer that there are some
cultures that still use base twelve and
what they do is they count on the
segments of your fingers one two three
four five six seven eight nine deck Eldo
just as easy to use right how many how
many arrows do you want so the next one
let's say we did three ^ ^ ^ arrow arrow
or whatever you want to call this 3 with
that that that that that is equivalent
to 3 to the to the double to the double
to the 3